welcome back so the so-called tolerant
left is showing their true colors again
the liberal mobs lashing out at Euphoria
star Sydney Sweeney calling her racist
after she posted photos from her mom's
60th birthday party so what was the
controversy well an attendee was wearing
and please brace yourselves here a blue
lives matter T-shirt oh the horror and
another photo shows guests wearing Maga
inspired hats saying make 60 great again
apparently they're ages too the
up-and-coming actress fighting back
saying you guys this is wild an innocent
celebration for my mom's milestone's
60th birthday has turned into an absurd
political statement which was not the
intention please stop making assumptions
um so what she means there Jimmy is
she's saying please stop assuming her
politics this woman is as conservative
as Hillary Clinton like you know she
works in the middle of Hollywood and
like she's not conservative she was
tweeting black lives matter a couple
years ago she just she's being shamed
for loving her family oh yeah well what
she needs to understand is she shouldn't
have touched this because it almost
amplifies it and gives it what it wants
there's a whole cottage industry of
people who get out of bed looking for
something to get mad at on Twitter
scientists have a word for them they're
called losers okay
she gave losers a lot of oxygen because
now they can run with this story but the
truth is everybody if you were
eavesdropping on someone else's party
looking to trash them for a tire and
everything in between it's because
you're not getting invited to parties
these are losers and it's like I'm say
that again they call them what
I'm a losers man no one listen to me
you're never you're never going to be at
a party and go wow I can't wait till the
guy gets offended and everything shows
up and that's the point you can't cater
to these people in society because
they're the worst among us we never like
them before social media we shouldn't be
pandering to them now she should have
given them not a make 60 great again hat
she should have taken an Instagram photo
that said make the middle finger great
again giving them the finger they
deserve nothing they I can kind of
sympathize she wants to have a career
she's an actress and she's good at it
evidently I haven't seen the show about
being incredibly happy uh but so you
know what I'm talking about when I say
there are actors in Hollywood big name
actors that will send me a picture of
Fox on in their green room but they
wouldn't touch being on Fox with a
10-foot pole because they're scared it's
like one of those things Joey like they
will call you they'll call Joey for a
happy birthday but they would never
tweeted yeah right because that would
taint them and I I imagine that she
probably her instincts were probably to
ignore it but I bet that her agent had
said you're going to have to address
this because we're not going to get
roles and you're going to and then the
agents get all spun up they don't
understand crisis Communications
resistance Twitter is the worst the
worst people in the world if you ignore
them they go away you know Harold we
talk about who we're socializing when
you've spent time with some of these
crazy people that that's all
progressives so you know a little bit
about how they think I don't understand
it what is the thought process here it's
actually this is a blue lives matter
t-shirt racist is is Donald Trump racist
we have it uh my most recent birthday
part of my upcoming we're going to have
uh uh t-shirts say fun FBI so I mean
so people so look this is absurd
absolutely absurd I don't care if these
people were wearing t-shirts or wearing
hats that they espouse political abuse
it's their party we are Americans for
those of us who believe in freedom
freedom extends when you wanna if those
those in my party who believe deeply in
pro-choice and those who believe deeply
in being able to do things behind your
behind closed doors in your home how on
Earth can you take this young lady on
who likely agrees with a lot of the
people exactly but even if she didn't
right it's her party that's that's right
happy birthday to her mom
also it could be her parents and you
know judge who cares it's her party no I
know I know judge I don't know if you've
seen the show but you're you're kind of
known for having a very exuberant social
life big parties Raves
um how would you react if somebody
weren't I'm with her Hillary Clinton
shirts one of your parties is this out
the serverless would react that nobody
would care first of all no one would
even notice but I got to tell you when
you talk about PR people her PR uh some
PR she's a member of I don't know some
agency and the a E network the pr person
for the network said your fans being
hurt with the posted photos of you with
your dad and a blue lives matter shirt
isn't unreasonable girly I mean they are
really I mean this PR person from the
network is really hitting it this is
what I think if you're offended by
someone who wears a blue lives matter
t-shirt why don't you send a letter to
your local police department and tell
them if I ever call you for 911 1 don't
show up because I've I've I've no longer
want to be associated with you you know
these people are so stupid they they it
amazes me she's right though 100 right
and this is the one comment I just want
to add one of the people responded with
that that make America 60 60 again have
is violence let me tell you if you've
ever been punched in the face you never
walk away going thank God that
that way oh man one of it's so much
worse all right we're gonna leave it
there before I get punched into Facebook
control room the fastest is up next I
want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now